huh
uh
all right then come on out
i'm not going to cut you
well get over here
thanks for the distraction gave me the
second i needed to take care of this
filth you're right that [ __ ] was ready
for a clash like for real
he was i'm fine i just need a second to
catch my breath and find my files
hold up is your name caitlyn now oh
you're with the feds in it
yeah we saw your vids it's pretty hard
of you to go after mary kelly on your
own you know it wasn't always on my own
who the hell are you're dead sick aren't
you
you tracked me to the slaughterhouse nah
blood
i've been tracking a mate from the epc
and now i'm here
it's [ __ ] up though in it all the
missing people ending up here like this
then i'm sorry i don't think there's
much hope for finding him alive
the kellys have got a sick little
operation going a kind of
human organ black market i've been
investigating them for months
and they got my [ __ ] files gotta feel
like [ __ ]
all right relax look i'm gonna call a
mate of mine and they'll get you
somewhere safe
i'll stay back and get angel i better
find your files
they seem big everything i've gathered
on mary kelly
almost enough to take her down ah [ __ ]
i guess that means you're our new best
friend because i think that's going to
be going after mary kelly now you know
all right an operative is on their way
to escort inspector lau
so let's find angel and inspector laos
files
i'll wait for your guy in here and
thanks
for your help i'm glad you're joining
for us
there's no doubt about it this whole
operation is meant to harvest organs
clan kelly's chopping off the parts they
want and burning the leftovers this is
straight up murder
maybe kelly's stealing organs to fund a
bloody empire
oh my days what happened to their faces
bags do some facial reconstruction take
a picture and i can run key details past
various databases
um
unfortunately i must confirm that this
is indeed angel lopez
[ __ ] angel
he knew the risks i did too but
never thought dedsec would get caught up
in this mary kelly is preying on
london's most vulnerable
she's a [ __ ] monster taking her out
needs to be
a deadset priority now we need to find
caitlin lowe's case files on mary kelly
and see if my conjecture may be correct
could mary kelly be in zero day
mary kelly heads up the most powerful
crime family in london clan kelly which
should at least be easy to remember
under her old man they were a bit player
then he died and her rival started
disappearing
her enemies her friends her family
they call her bloody mary for a reason
early on mary abandoned cash in favor of
cryptocurrency
and brought the kenny's criminal
business online it makes
weapon smuggling drug running money
laundering all a lot easier without a
cash trail
the woman single-handedly modernized
organized crime in london
she considers herself to be untouchable
case in point from my files you
retrieved
darla covington 19 sasha haddad 28
radik stockkovic 24
all disappeared it's difficult to find
good out these days isn't it love
most people they ain't driven not like
you
because they feel worthless don't they
the way that the world is how it uses
people it's horrible
it's nice that you have a purpose oh
that'll be me love
we aren't finished here this
was a courtesy
oh give my regards to their families
it's horrible losing someone you love
nice meeting you caitlyn
as you can see she'll never respond to
interrogation
but there is one place she feels
comfortable talking
the sandstone residence inspector lao
thinks a police bug in the kelly's
headquarters may have the evidence she
needs to finally convict bloody mary
sandstone is their center of operations
i
know the data on that bug will take her
down get it for me
and i swear i'll put her away forever
pushing the coordinates to your optics
sabine here inspector lao i'm curious
how you think you can bring mary kelly
to justice now
with no backing even before albion took
over policing you couldn't lock her up
and she goes on treating humans like
cattle i had to work within the system
yes it was corrupt i knew it i just
didn't know
how bad it was i thought a strong enough
case couldn't be buried
wrong [ __ ] feds are corrupt all
around up and down
why should we believe things will ever
change because i'm taking it to a
contact in the attorney general's office
an honest solicitor with a hard-on for
organized crime
specifically for mary kelly look our
methods may differ
but i want to help those people as much
as you do
all right but however this goes down
there's no way we're letting mary slip
the net again
that's not how dedsec does things let's
get to sandstone
security here is state of the art quite
impenetrable
unless of course you flew a drone
through the window one of mary's mouth
breathers left open
the recording device is in a security
room getting there should be a simple
matter of navigating the vents
what the [ __ ] she's using these people
as house servants
against their will horrible in itself
but a million times worse knowing they
end up as unwilling organ donors
[Music]
you have a real [ __ ] attitude problem
do you know that
face i need help
[Laughter]
[ __ ] idiot do you piss everyone off
the way you're pissing me off
wanker
[Music]
stupid
oh yeah
look at the stain of you what you've
done to yourself after everything i've
done for you
you made me a slave all of us
please let me go take this thing out
back to your old life back to nothing
back to you 2.5 screaming blighters in
your dead-end job and sucking off the
doll
you don't want that love this
microchip is scary i know but i got to
keep tracks on my merchandise and i
and this kitchen knife that won't do it
love
cutting yourself affects my bottom line
i can't believe like this anymore no
you are right there
it's all right sweetheart because i have
another use for you
oh paying attention all we're good be
sure and spread the word
you know where this one goes get these
two and all the others over to their
venue and ready for the sale
right away ma'am also the foreign
investors have already landed and the
drones are programmed
ready to deliver the invitations and the
coordinates to all the guests
is that initiative i'm smelling peter
initiative can be a dangerous thing
can be misinterpreted
[ __ ] psych
this is insane how did mary get her
hands on this kind of tech
it takes a sick mind to come up with
killer microchips
perhaps a diseased mind but definitely
an ingenious one perfect psych profile
for a group like zero day wouldn't you
say
her affiliations aren't my priority
badly she's keeping these people
enslaved
and it sounds as if she's selling them
this is huge
that's the microchip in action you
either live as a slave or die with your
organs up for sale
i don't know which one's worse dead sec
we'll have to crash that slave
auction get all the information we can
out of there
i'm empty
i thought i had him
suspect is injured
bloody muppet is that the best
give yourself up
i need a hand here
shooting
oh god oh god oh god
[Music]
oh
[Music]
target is firing
you're a natural next step is to wait
for now to get back to us but don't wait
here that would be a [ __ ] idea
true say
[Music]
dead good glad to establish a foundation
of trust
i'm ready to show you the contract i'm
investigating go to the gbb
[Music]
sweet suffering jesus people are
actually just [ __ ] worse
ah the gbb once considered the world's
greatest public broadcaster now
considered quote
quite [ __ ] this is where you'll find out
big contract
no doors for you today sorry there's a
safe access point on the roof
that should be a prime peeping spot
uh
me
[Music]
disturbance detected beginning to
[Music]
investigation
so
everything you are is in your brain
your love your fear your dreams
even the cheeky ones are all electrical
signals firing back and forth between
your ears
this right here is more powerful than
any computer
but it has its limitations
i watched my mother succumb to motor
neuron disease
and her loss made me realize that death
comes to us
all but
what if we could change that
what if we could scan your brain
and upload the neural map to the cloud
well that would mean the end of human
suffering
of death itself and the beginning of a
new society where war
oppression disease are all worries of
the past
hello my name is skye larsen
i'm ceo of brokertech and this
is daybreak
now since all of you have signed up for
a waitlist i'm sure you're eager to see
how daybreak really works but before we
do that
i'll ask the technicians at the board to
cut the live feed
we wouldn't want any uninvited guests
recording these trade secrets
daybreak is an imaging system which
scans